Et pour une certaine raison, nous considérons cela atypique
bien que, comme je l'ai dit, les femmes constituent la moitié de la population.
Quelle preuve avons-nous pour expliquer ces différences ?
Si nous regardons l'anatomie,
les vaisseaux sanguins qui entourent le coeur sont plus petits chez les femmes,
et ces vaisseaux sanguins développent des maladies différemment
chez les hommes et chez les femmes.
Le test utilisé pour déterminer si quelqu'un a un risque de crise cardiaque,
a été initialement créé, testé et perfectionné sur les hommes.
Il n'est donc pas aussi efficace chez les femmes.
Si nous pensons aux médicaments,
que nous utilisons régulièrement, comme l'aspirine.
Nous donnons de l'aspirine à des hommes sains pour empêcher une crise cardiaque.
Mais savez-vous si donner de l'aspirine à une femme en bonne santé
est nocif ou non ?
Cette question nous indique simplement que
nous ne faisons qu'effleurer la surface.
La médecine urgentiste est en constante évolution.
Dans combien de domaines médicaux sauveurs de vie,
comme le cancer et les crises cardiaques,
y a-t-il des différences importantes entre les hommes et les femmes
que nous pourrions utiliser ?
Ou bien, comment cela se fait-il que certains aient le nez qui coule
plus que d'autres
ou que les antidouleurs donnés pour des orteils écrasés
fonctionnent chez certains mais pas chez d'autres ?
L'Institut de Médecine a dit que chaque cellule a un sexe.
Qu'est-ce que cela signifie ?
Le sexe est de l'ADN.
Le genre est la façon dont quelqu'un se présente en société.
Et ces deux choses ne correspondent pas toujours,
comme nous pouvons le voir dans la population transgenre.
Il est important de réaliser que, depuis la conception,
chaque cellule de notre corps --
de notre peau, nos cheveux, notre cœur et nos poumons --
contient notre ADN unique
et que cet ADN contient des chromosomes qui déterminent
le fait que nous soyons mâle ou femelle, homme ou femme.
Auparavant, nous pensions
que c'étaient ces chromosomes-là qui déterminent le sexe --
XY si vous êtes un mâle, XX si vous êtes une femelle --
qui déterminaient aussi si vous naitriez avec des ovaires ou des testicules
et que c'étaient les hormones sexuelles produites par ces organes
qui étaient responsables des différences qu'il y a entre les deux sexes.
Mais nous savons aujourd'hui que cette théorie est fausse,
ou tout du moins incomplète.
Heureusement, des scientifiques comme le Dr. Page de l'Institut Whitehead,
qui travaille sur le chromosome Y,
et le Dr. Yang d'UCLA
ont trouvé la preuve qui nous dit que ces chromosomes qui déterminent le sexe,
qui sont dans chaque cellule de votre corps
restent actifs toute notre vie
et pourraient être responsables des différences que nous observons
dans le dosage des médicaments
ou pourquoi il y a des différences entre les hommes et les femmes
quant à la sensibilité et la sévérité des maladies.
Cette connaissance change tout.
Et c'est à ces scientifiques de continuer à trouver ces preuves.
Mais c'est aux cliniciens de traduire, aujourd'hui, les données
au chevet des patients.
Maintenant.
Pour aider cela, je suis co-fondatrice d'une organisation nationale
appelée Collaboration en Santé des femmes pour le Sexe et le Genre.
Nous collectons ces données qui sont disponibles pour l'enseignement
et les soins aux patients.
Nous travaillons pour faire venir les éducateurs médicaux.
C'est un gros travail.
Cela change la façon dont la médecine est enseignée depuis ses débuts.
Mais je crois en eux.
Je sais que nous verrons la valeur de la prise en compte du sexe du patient
dans le curriculum actuel.
Il est question d'entraîner correctement les futurs agents de santé.
Régionalement,
je suis co-créatrice d'une division du département de Médecine Urgentiste
à l'université de Brown :
le Sexe et le Genre dans la Médecine Urgentiste.
Nous conduisons des recherches pour déterminer les différences
entre les hommes et les femmes
en condition urgente,
comme les maladies et crises cardiaques, les septicémies, les overdoses.
Mais nous croyons également que l'éducation est primordiale.
Nous avons créé un modèle éducatif à 360°.
Nous avons des programmes pour les médecins, infirmières, étudiants
et patients.
Car cela ne peut pas être laissé aux dirigeants du système de santé.
Nous avons un rôle dans le changement.
Mais je dois vous prévenir : ce n'est pas facile.
En fait, c'est difficile.
C'est essentiel de changer notre vision de la médecine,
de la santé et de la recherche.
Cela change notre relation au système de santé.
Il n'y a pas de retour en arrière possible.
Nous en savons juste assez
pour savoir que nous ne le faisions pas correctement.
Martin Luther King a dit :
« Le changement n'arrive pas inévitablement,
il nécessite une lutte permanente. »
Le premier pas vers le changement est la conscience.
Il n'est pas seulement question d'améliorer les soins médicaux des femmes
mais de soins médicaux personnalisés et individualisés pour tous.
Cette sensibilisation a le pouvoir de transformer les soins médicaux
pour les hommes et les femmes.
A partir de maintenant, j'aimerais que vous demandiez à votre médecin
si les traitements que vous recevez sont spécifiques à vos sexe et genre.
Ils ne connaîtront peut-être pas la réponse,
pas encore.
Mais la conversation a commencé et, ensemble, nous pouvons apprendre.
Souvenez-vous que pour moi et mes collègues dans ce domaine,
votre sexe et votre genre importent.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)